hello everyone welcome to brilliant
minds bold questions a five-part virtual
event series exploring questions being
addressed by some of the world's top
researchers
each talk pairs speakers and moderators
from across disciplines
sectors and the world to explore
questions shaping our future
if you're not familiar with us cfar is a
canadian-based global research
organization
that convenes extraordinary minds to
address the most important questions
facing science and humanity
i'm alyssa strome i'm the executive
director of the pan canadian ai strategy
at cfar
and it's my pleasure to introduce you
today to blake richards and anil seth
blake is an assistant professor at the
montreal neurological institute and
school of computer
science at mcgill university and is a
canada cfr ai
chair and cfar fellow in our learning
and machines and brains program
anal is a professor of cognitive and
computational science
at the university of sussex and is the
co-director of cfar's brain
mind and consciousness program and is
the author of the upcoming book
being you a new science of consciousness
and today we're going to explore the
provocative question
can ai be conscious today's session will
last about 30 minutes and we'll start
with a few questions to kick off the
discussion but i also invite our
audience members to send your questions
in
at any time using the zoom q a function
we'll get to a few of your questions a
little bit later in the discussion
so let's jump right in and we'll start
with a really
fundamental question to what extent is
consciousness relevant to ai
and vice versa can ai help us better
understand human consciousness and
can insights into consciousness help us
advance ai
so blake let's start with you
thanks very much alyssa so i think
consciousness is very much so relevant
to ai and vice versa
and the reason i would argue it is
is ultimately because i think that the
very definition of artificial
intelligence implies that
here's what i mean by that so if we ask
ourselves what is artificial
intelligence
and how is it different from other
components of computer science as a
discipline
i would argue not everyone would agree
with me but i would argue
that what marks artificial intelligence
is that it is the attempt
to program computers to behave like we
humans do and to have the same
capabilities that we humans do
this perspective goes back to the
origins of the discipline
when alan turing first wrote his article
in 1950 on
intelligence and machines and proposed
the turing test
to see whether or not a computer could
fool
a human judge into thinking that it was
in fact human
and so if we if we take this perspective
that really artificial intelligence is
not just about getting machines that do
useful stuff because that's all of
computer science
it's about getting machines that behave
like us and have the same abilities that
we have
then intel then consciousness is
necessarily relevant to ai
insofar as any of our capabilities are
based in our consciousness so anything
that we can do that's fundamentally
about our consciousness
must necessarily be a relevant question
for
ai and in in turn
i would say that if you are concerned
with trying to engineer a system that
can exhibit
the capabilities that a human being does
necessarily you're going to have to
contend with
questions that are related to questions
of what our consciousness is
and how it informs our behavior and that
will mean that necessarily
in doing ai you will end up stumbling
upon things that will
speak to our own consciousness and and
help us to understand our own
consciousness better
great thank you for for that perspective
very much focused on
uh definitions and objectives i know
what do you think
this is cool because i was i wasn't sure
what blake was going to say and i
actually agree with a decent amount of
it which is
you know not always the case uh which is
so
um we promised the entire session
yeah let's see what happens but so this
idea that
ai has originally conceived as
replicating the general functional
capabilities of human being
yeah i think that does imply that we
have to
understand which of those functions in
humans
are manifest or mediated by our being
conscious and and
and many of them seem to be we for many
of the things that are distinctively
human in our repertoire of competences
our abilities to integrate lots of
information in a single scene
to generalize to new circumstances
quickly these
are tied up with our conscious
experiences in ways that we don't fully
understand from a neuroscientific
perspective
so certainly if we want to build
machines with those capabilities it's
going to help
to understand how these functions
interact with
the mechanisms that underlie
consciousness in humans
at the same time i think it is important
to
draw a distinction between intelligence
on the one hand
and consciousness on the other it can
still be the case that
building a generally artificial
intelligent or human level intelligent
machine might require insight into
consciousness but not
every aspect of intelligence necessarily
needs consciousness
and certainly not every conscious
creature
is intelligent in the way that that
humans are
so the mechanisms might be both related
but they might come apart as well and so
there's there's something i think quite
important here which is that
there's an assumption that some people
hold and again i don't think any of us
necessarily do that
that consciousness is just going to come
along for the ride as ai gets smarter
and smarter and smarter
and i'm not quite sure that that's a oh
i don't think that's a safe assumption
at all and consciousness is something
that at least i think is present in in
many other
species besides humans and probably has
very specific
uh dedicated mechanisms so yes
think about how they come together but
recognize that they are in fact
different things
very very interesting i really
appreciate your your distinction between
intelligence and consciousness and and
the you know the underpinning mechanisms
of each and
the roles and applications of each very
very interesting
all right so as we continue to think
about uh these questions
you know i think one of the most
important considerations that arises
that's very
hotly debated and discussed is are the
ethical questions
so you know we should ask ourselves is
it even ethical for us
as researchers and society to be
striving
for conscious machines or machines that
at least seem
conscious to us so what about the ethics
and what do you see as the ethical
considerations
it's a complicated landscape but it's a
hugely important one and we've seen over
the recent over recent years that
ethical concerns about the development
of ai have become
quite quite prominent and there's lots
of discussion of policy and regulation
which are rightly focused on the
potential risks
and dangers of ai as it becomes smarter
and smarter
but the ethics of artificial
consciousness are slightly different
they're not just an extrapolation of the
same thing
as i just said it's it's not i think
sometimes
the ethics of ai treat or artificial
consciousness treat consciousness as
this inevitable extension of the
trajectory of ai
and if we set that aside and and and
realize that actually
conscious building a conscious machine
an actually conscious machine might
require you know
actually trying to do that aspiring to
do that rather than just
modeling some of the functions of
consciousness in machines it gets
it gets more complicated ethically
it is not a good idea i think we need to
be very careful about striving with the
just the unalloyed objective to build
machines that have
conscious experiences this is a very
ethically problematic thing to do
because as soon as you
do that then you have the these
these systems become moral subjects we
have to care
about the experiences they have and we
are as a species pretty bad about caring
about the experiences
that things other than humans have and
we're pretty bad about caring about the
experiences of some other humans
as well and we tend to intuitively make
this judgment based on similarity
how similar is system x to me that's how
much
moral uh concern i feel
and we can see that as we extrapolate in
the animal kingdom our intuitions become
less secure as as we deal with species
that are more and more
dissimilar to us the real challenge for
a putatively conscious machine is that
we wouldn't even
know what the relevant ethical issues
are intuitions would be completely
unguided we'd have no
anchor they might not smile they might
not exhibit
responses to pain in the way that people
do so we risk becoming
unmoored here and the worry that i have
is that
it although we don't know what it would
take to build a conscious machine we
don't know what the sufficient
conditions
are we also don't know what it would not
take
it could be indeed that consciousness is
simply a matter of very very
sophisticated
information processing of the sort that
can be instantiated
in uh near future computer um
in which case we might have already
built a conscious machine and just not
realize it
on the other hand it could be that no
consciousness depends
on what something is made out of you any
near future computer will at best be a
simulation
of consciousness rather than actually
having conscious
experiences now some people have very
strong intuitions
about whether this is the case or not i
tend to be quite agnostic about that
we don't from a neuroscience perspective
it's still at least from my view
unclear about whether something needs to
be made out of carbon
in order to be conscious or whether
something can be made out of silicon
if you wire it up the right way so this
is the big problem with the ethics there
are just so many
unknowns out there that we have to be
tread very carefully and have what i
would like to call a kind of preemptive
ethics it takes to takes it i think it
really behooves us to be precautionary
about this
not stop research in this area at all
but just be mindful of the things that
we don't yet know
yeah i think you you make some
interesting points blake you want to
jump right in
yes um there's there's a couple of
things i i'd like to respond to in that
so
it actually ends up touching upon the
areas that uh
nl and i diverge in our opinions so
one of the things that i personally
don't agree with is is the idea that we
can fully
divorce the question of consciousness
from
intelligence or from behavioral
capabilities in general
and i'm personally not convinced that
consciousness
as a thing that is separate from
behavioral capabilities
is even studyable from a scientific
mindset i think that you know if we ask
ourselves how is it that we know
that other human beings are conscious or
how is it that many of us would say that
our dogs are conscious
et cetera um per and nils anil's comment
regarding ethics
i think arguably you know we judge it
based on behavior and whether or not we
see
some of the same behaviors in those
agents that we ourselves
engage in and which are exhibitions of
our own
experience and i would argue that
from a scientific perspective if another
creature
exhibits behaviors that are
indistinguishable from those
of another creature that we are willing
to call conscious
you cannot then not apply the label
conscious to that
and so i i think that you know when we
talk about the ethical considerations
this this all ties into a
an idea from the uh philosopher dan
dennett who's also a member of uh
an anna's cfart program of called the
intentional stance
and roughly this is the idea that with
some
creatures some agents some machines it
is more natural for us
to to interact with them if we assume
that they have
intentions and subjective experience and
if
if that's the case if you if you find
that the intentional stance
is applicable to a particular creature
that you can only really
easily explain its behavior and its
actions
via uh an interpretation of it as
another conscious intentional agent then
as far as i'm concerned it is conscious
and so then when we get to the ethical
question i think
it's uh really fundamentally
um no different from the ethical
question we've we face
continually with all other creatures
which is
how different are we willing to have a
creature be
for us to then not consider it as
worthy of ethical consideration and and
i guess with regards to the question of
you know what is the ethics of creating
a conscious machine
i i don't personally think that
there's you know any
there's any way to to do ai without
the potential for creating a conscious
machine down the road
because as i said at the start the goal
is to replicate the behavioral
capabilities of human beings
and and as i've articulated here i think
that necessitates
an understanding that if we're
successful in this research program we
will eventually develop machines
that we have to take the intentional
stance with in which case
you know we we will have done it so um
i i am personally of the opinion that
right from the get-go we've already made
the decision
that we're comfortable with the ethical
question
you know what if we make a conscious
machine we are because if we weren't
we wouldn't be engaged in the quest for
ai
and and then the the more tricky ethical
question is
how different do the machines have to be
or rather how similar
before we acknowledge them as as another
conscious entity worthy of consideration
in that way
and and how much more work do we do and
how how urgent
is the work that we're doing to
understand and examine
the ethical questions of creating uh a
conscious machine and
you've both argued that um you know
we're sort of on that path and we should
be prepared and we should be
uh thinking about these ethical
questions are we are we putting enough
effort into those ethical questions
right now or should we be doing more
it's hard to say i mean there are some
debates but the the
the problem is that there's very little
ground truth on on which to build
um but you know the issues are certainly
in the air i have to say that for me the
more the more
challenging context is in things a
little bit outside of ai like organoids
people are building these sort of
typically caricatured as lab grown mini
brains um
they are collections of neurons grown in
a dish that have
increasingly brain-like structures now
these are very
functionally simple they don't really do
anything yet hardly anything
yet they're made out of the same stuff
that normal brains are made out of so
immediately you set to one side one of
the biggest philosophical and
metaphysical unknowns which is
does the substrate matter in an organoid
it's the same substrate and
and there you know there already are
quite advanced ethical discussions among
regulatory and funding agencies
about what should be done and i think
quite rightly at the moment
the question the prospect that organoids
are conscious is not
impinging research there because there's
a great deal of medical value
but it's good that the question is being
revisited uh
as as the technology develops
so it it's constant uh we need to we
need to keep having these conversations
and
and advancing our knowledge and our
thinking about these questions
yeah and just the one other thing i mean
that you're absolutely right but i think
the
the thing will come and this is sort of
taking a slightly different
uh slant from blake but we're already in
a case where
ai systems can generate things that
give us a strong impression of being
conscious you only have to
you have to combine video deep fakes
with a language generator like gpt3
and you've got something that gives a
pretty good impression of being
a conscious agent and so i think we as
humans are likely to
attribute consciousness to a system
quite quite quickly if it gives a
superficial appearance of being similar
to us
that might you know that might distort
our circle of moral concern um
in quite distressing ways indeed
okay so um thinking
you know looking towards the future uh
maybe not too far into the future but
into the future
let's say that both the science and the
ethics have advanced
far enough that we're able to create
machines that have or appear to have to
your point you know
consciousness so can you describe what
that might look like
and also what the consequences might be
blake do you want to start on that one
sure
so i mean i think that there are certain
fundamental features
of what practically we mean by
human consciousness that um
for example uh you know a deep fake uh
would not have um which is for
you know just to pull out a few examples
um
a sense of one's past experience and an
ability to articulate like i experienced
xyz at this time in this place this is
related to something we call episodic
memories in the brain
so one of the things right off the bat
that i would say would be required
for consciousness in the practical sense
of it would be ai systems
that have an understanding that they are
an agent that has experiences
and they they can articulate what has
happened to them in the past and how
that relates to their current decisions
um or at least have some internal sense
of that even if they can't verbally
articulate it
um you know likewise i would say that
the uh ability to to have a sort of
sense of because of
is is part of that equation as well so
the ability to sense that like
i acted in this way because of this
thing
and have that framing of ones internally
of one's own
actions would be critical to to the
entire edifice that we would call
consciousness whether in a human being
or a machine
so what i imagine that these things
ultimately looking like in the future
are ultimately ai agents that
that can articulate that sense of like
i am an agent who has experienced stuff
through time and i made my decisions
based on those experiences
and and if they'd articulated internally
or externally to us that will
be a very different type of behavior um
than we get from current ai systems for
example
which are more like kind of pure
perceptual
kind of habit-like systems right right
i know what what do you think about what
it's going to look like
i mean it's hard to predict the future
um
one perspective that's kind of
interesting to think about here is
is to blake's point really what what are
the properties that will always be
conserved in anything
that is sensibly called conscious like
if you think about evolutionary biology
right and you think about what uh what a
creature
that evolves on a completely different
planet in some sort of liquid in some
alien sea
it's probably going to look a bit like a
fish there are just constraints about
how things move
through water that will constrain what
marine
creatures look like you know physically
universal sorts of things right
um there's a lot of variety but there
are some things that you can predict
so what what are there similar things we
can say about consciousness so there are
certain
are there certain spaces in this whole
volume of possible minds
uh that will always be visited by any
conscious
system i'm not sure you know quite what
those would be blake's made a couple of
suggestions
um that may be the case uh it may be
that we every conjure system integrates
perceptual scenes in a particular way
but um it's really difficult to know
it's and i think we have to be
again careful of this tendency to see
things see things through the lens of
what it is to be human this
anthropomorphic
bias that we have and we've seen all
through science fiction
authors play with this bias it's some
sometimes always there almost by
assumption you know
from little green men on mars to hal to
arva and ava and ex machina um
the the conscious agents in science
fiction bear interesting relations
to to their human mirrors and
just to bring dan dennett back into it
he's made the point that we're building
tools
tools not colleagues and i think future
ai is going to bear a
complementary relationship to us it's
going to fill spaces
for regions of the space of possible
minds that complement
our abilities in useful ways rather than
just simply replace them
that would be that would be great okay
i'm excited to tell you that we have
literally dozens and dozens of questions
coming in
from the audience and it's going to be
very hard for me to pick them all but
we'll we'll try to find
a few that we can get to right off the
bat so here's one
do you think that subjective experience
or qualia
a has nothing to do with the
computational intelligence
displayed by the brain b has a useful
computational function by itself
or c is a side effect of another
mechanism which is useful
for computational intelligence of brains
so if i might respond to that so this is
again where
anil and i will diverge so i do not
think that the word
qualia is a suitable word for scientific
application
because by definition it is something
immeasurable and this is this is where
i i end up just kind of objecting to the
idea that consciousness could ever be
anything
other than in reference to human beings
because i think that if you try to
articulate that there is this
special thing that can exist in the
absence of a set of measurable behaviors
that we
recognize as consciousness you have
immediately rendered that special thing
unobservable to scientists and
unquantifiable in any kind of meaningful
way
so i i personally think that you know
qualia uh has nothing to do with
with anything in the brain because i
don't think it's a scientific
concept personally i know a lot of
people don't like that perspective
probably i
know won't but that that's honestly no
you you're right you're right
this is this is somewhere where we where
we interestingly diversion i mean it's
not just us there's a lot of diverse
opinions about this for me
and i'll keep you very short so we can
get other questions the whole science of
consciousness starts with that i mean
it's the one thing we can't be mistaken
about there
are conscious experiences um we i can be
mistaken about everything else in the
world what's out there am i staring at a
cup or is it a hallucination
is it an illusion um am i in
the lake district or in canada i could
be mistaken about everything apart from
the fact that i'm having a conscious
experience right now
um there is a there there the fact that
it's difficult to measure is an
epistemological problem
but it doesn't doesn't uh doesn't get
rid of the thing
from scientific inquiry but to the to
the question i'm going to say
b now if i'm trying to remember what a b
and c were now
right but i think i think i think it was
b consciousness is related
to uh things going on in the brain that
are also related to intelligence
and it's associated with useful
functions it's not epithelial
and it's also not completely unrelated
so b is my my choice
perfect a hybrid there absolutely okay
here's another one uh
do you think the ability to feel
emotions and or physical sensations
such as pain are a requirement for
consciousness let me
take that one first i i think this is in
human beings and animals very likely yes
but pro but
potentially as just a contingent factor
of the way
the neural substrate of consciousness
evolves our brains are fundamentally
about regulating our bodies this is kind
of the position i've
i've been arguing for for years um our
brains are for regulating our bodies
emotions moods pain these kinds of
sensations are quite primary to our
survival prospects and at least in
humans all of our
other cognitive apparatus is built on
top of these
these basic regulatory systems and we
already know from from work of people
like antenna dimazio going back years
that actually these
emotions play an important role in how
we deploy intelligent behavior in our
rationality in our reasoning
so even without making any claims about
whether emotions are
necessary constitutively necessary for
consciousness
you can make a good argument that that
simulating or modeling emotions is going
to be
very very useful in endowing artificial
systems
with human-like rationality
great great way to think about it uh
here's another quick one
um back to some of the ethical questions
that we were discussing earlier so if
if we are to reach a point if we were to
reach a point where we agree
that we have created conscious machines
would consciousness imply that such
machines would have rights
independent of their human creators
would they be like children
who have rights independent of their
parents or would they be like higher
animals
which have consciousness and the
capacity to suffer but do not have
rights in all states that's a very
political question
well if i might jump in on that one
i think that the important thing to
remember is that
rights are something that we as a
society endow to
creatures and so i i'm not
i think personally that the question of
whether they would have rights
it really does come down to actually a
practical question of does the society
endow those rights to those
individuals you know there were
societies in the past and there still
are to some extent that do not endow
rights to
certain human beings and there are
likewise societies that endow a great
deal of rights to
non-human animals that they wouldn't
endow other non-human animals
try harming a horse in the united
kingdom for example
but um the the the reality then is that
when we ask this this ethical question
it really is just a practical social
cultural question
would our society feel compelled to give
rights to these
agents and that might have a lot to do
with what their role in
society is i suspect
yeah i would say the simple answer is is
yes if if society has
in general comes to a reasonable
conclusion that we've built systems that
have ex
conscious experiences then we're obliged
to take an ethical stance
with respect to them if they have the
capacity to suffer or to have frustrated
preferences
then their moral subjects and we can
decide exactly what rights they have
it doesn't mean they're full-fledged
people uh it would mean they might have
rights in the same way that some
non-human animals have rights and so i
think
that part of it is very clear the
difficult question for me still remains
are we going to underextend
those rights to overextend them based on
an incomplete understanding of the
sufficient conditions
for building a conscious machine still
so many questions to answer and so much
more
work to do but thank you so much blake
and anil this has just been an
absolutely fascinating conversation the
q a is blowing up i've never seen it
like this before
um i think that's all we have time for
today unfortunately and so i want to
thank all of our audience members for
joining us and participating so actively
and i'd especially like to thank blake
and and now for sharing your thoughts
and your insights
with us uh please audience members
please feel free to visit our website
cfar.ca to find out more about the
series and to view recordings of
previous talks
the recording of this talk will be
available early next week
thanks so much everyone and have a great
[Music]
day
you